Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So thank you for the invitation.
Um,
as young was saying,
I'm a sociologist that Goldsmiths,
um,
I'm interested in citizenship and gender and technology and invention,
which is very much what this book is all about.
Um,
so I'm going to tell you a little bit about the research project that underpins
this new publication and this extensively about Victorian engineering,
the history of patenting as radical feminists,
cultures of invention,
but I'm here to do pretty much is a bit of cycling,
sewing and suffrage storytelling.
So my research tells a story of inventors who helped to shape the landscape in
which women could move and new ways independently unchaperoned in public space
who embraced a plethora of new technologies such as the bicycle,
the sewing machine,
you waterproof and woolen fabrics and a range of new media and who pushed it,
the perimeters of established forms of gendered citizenship.
And all of this,
I believe and I will argue,
can be told through the history of cycle where,
but first of all,
why am I looking at cycle where in the first place?
Why does cycle,
where matter?
Can I find out who's a cyclist here?
Oh,
okay.
Quite a lot of you.
Terrific.
Okay.
Um,
so initially the idea for this came from an amazing postdoc that I'd been doing,
um,
where I was,
I'm studying,
um,
contemporary cycling research.
Um,
and it was about the cultures of cycling.
I was looking at four different field sites around the UK with Rachel Oldroyd
and her great project.
I'm exploring in some cases why cycle rates in some places in the UK when much
high than others.
It involved a whole mixed methods approach of ethnography in a lot of
interviews.
Um,
but I was really struck by how unprovoked please come in,
um,
how unprovoked cyclists would often talk about what they would wear to cycle and
the effect this had on other users in some circumstances looking like a proper
cyclist enabled people to carve out cycling identities and kind of legitimize
the space on the road and in others.
And women were particularly articulate about this and it's being visibly
identifiable as a cyclist,
sometimes resulted in unwelcome responses from other road users and people also
seem to identify with this struggle to find appropriate clothing,
the fitted on the bike and also for when you arrived at your destination and
female cyclist also lamented the limited range of cycle where are available to
them in relation to what was available for men more broadly.
They talked about having to hack or adapt their own clothing,
buy men's wear and do things with that because they felt there was a limited
kind of high tech range for them.
And at the time also the media was starting to identify a particular type of
dress cyclist,
the Lycra lout,
um,
and here a seemingly appropriate technical materiality for cycling Lycra was
becoming shorthand for kind of an anti social form of mobility.
So clearly what cyclists wall mattered and it mattered a lot.
So I began to ask,
why does cycle,
where matter,
where do these anxieties come from and what can we learn about what we wear to
cycle today from learning more about what we've worn in the past.
So my research focuses on a very small period of history,
1895 to 1899.
It was a radical intersection of new technology and social and cultural change.
And it was when the bicycle booms swept through this country.
Um,
and it was also a time of address reform and emancipation activities.
We're gaining kind of traction advocating for more women's rights and freedoms.
There's a growth of new printed media,
particularly around cycling periodicals and an influx of new ideas from
travelers from abroad.
So I've been looking particularly at what early cyclists war to ride bikes and
cycle where really provides an interesting lens,
I think,
into society.
So as a sociologist,
I consider clothing as a device that reflects and also producers,
social,
cultural and political worlds.
And clothing is not just something that covers or protects bodies,
but thinking of it as a technology that enables and constrains different forms
of mobility.
And in the 1890s,
clothing was a critical means through each bodies are made to fit both
physically and also ideologically with changing ideas about being in a,
moving through public space and attaching to all these new and exciting
technologies and somebodies fitted much easier with these new technologies and
somebody had to be made to fit.
So I've been focusing particularly on middle and upper class women because they
were at the cutting edge of fashion.
They had money to embrace new technology as well as the leisure time to enjoy
it.
Um,
they had exposure to media and ideas from around the world and the social and
cultural capital to push back against conventional social codes and norms.
So what was happening in the 1890s?
I'm going to set the scene a little bit with a letter.
Um,
it was written in 1897 by kitty j Buckman to a friend of hers about her cycling
experiences.
And she writes this,
she says,
many says,
Oxford is the most bigoted place in the kingdom.
It certainly cannot be worse to write an Oxford then in London,
especially London suburbs.
It's awful.
One one's nerves of iron,
the shouts in the yells of children,
defin won the women's Shriek with laughter or grown and his and all sorts of
remarks or shouted occasionally,
some not fit for publication.
One needs to be very brave to stand all that and it makes one feel mad.
And one's idea of humanity at large sink to a very low standard.
So,
um,
kitty clearly loves cycling and there's lots of letters between her and her
friends about how much they loved it.
But the fact that she says it took nerves of iron to ride it clearly wasn't
always a relaxing or I'm safe pastime in late 19th century Britain rather as
evoked by these letters.
It was fraught with verbal and sometimes even physical assault,
um,
from general public in some places.
So why was this,
why did mobile women get treated in this way?
What were they doing and wearing to elicit such social violence?
And how,
and in what ways did they respond?
So,
so both men and women really enthusiastically took to cycling,
but they both had very different experiences.
In the 1890s,
it was considerably easier for upper class men initially because their bodies
and society's understandings about masculine mobility and their closing meant
they fitted with the bicycle much more easily.
And as Jennifer Hargraves rights,
you know,
sports constituted a unique form of cultural life.
There were overwhelmingly symbols of masculinity and chauvinism embodying
aggressive displays,
a physical power and,
and competitiveness in the 19th century.
There's no question that sports were the natural domain of men and to be good at
them was essentially masculine.
And the popularity of cycling and cycle racing in particular really helped to
shape kind of men's attachment to cycling as well as their cycle where
reinforcing it's masculine appeal and cutting edge designs for racing bites also
trickled down into the consumer market.
Some men were much more easily to um,
to adopt a confident hightech cycling consumer right from the start.
And a slew of popular periodicals such as these,
the hub and the wheeler.
Um,
we're very quick to respond to this popular interest and they regularly publish
details of all the racing events and showcased winners in collectible kind of
commemorative posters like this.
So you can see kind of a discourse of heroism.
We're embedded in these accounts that powerfully linked masculinity and cycling.
We see language such as speed and agility and performance champion professional
and skill.
Um,
and you can see also a men's clothing wasn't terribly much of an issue here
either.
They were much more easily able to discard things.
We're seeing that was seen as kind of problematic on a bicycle to the point
where there's not much even happening there.
And a to the left you can see almost the prelude to kind of cycling skin suits
even happening a hundred over 110 years ago.
So women in cycling,
women to found cycling incredibly exciting and we can probably barely imagine
the parallel sense of kind of excitement and freedom and independence that would
have come from cycling at that time for them,
however their bodies and dress and mobile engagement and public space,
we're much more complicated.
Up until the mid 1880s middle and upper class women's bodies in Victorian
society were defined by the moral responsibility of reproduction and deeply
rooted in kind of one place being the home exercise was deemed unnecessary and
healthy even,
and even detrimental to our matrimonial duties.
Given her main purpose was the caring and bearing of children and fashions may
not have been always as complicated as this French,
um,
visiting dress.
But they stencil,
I mean forced many of these beliefs about women's role in society.
They can prized up to seven pounds of heavy petticoats long,
um,
floor length skirts,
tightly laced corset,
blouses,
jackets,
fails,
hats,
gloves,
and much more.
And together these restrictions on women's bodies produced kind of a largely in
mobile citizen and capable.
It was seen as being able to do much physical or indeed mental economical kind
of political movement.
However,
by the 19th century plus the ninth century,
things were really changing.
Women's rights activists were continuing to agitate for women's freedom of
movement out of the home into education and business.
Public debate about the importance of exercise for women was actually changing.
And doctors who had previously been very negative about it with suddenly coming
out and cautiously recommending it.
Um,
and dress reform was emerging in the UK at for both sexes and the UK is rational
dress society had been around since the 1880s now campaigning for what they
called him irrational dress over,
I'm sorry for rational dress over irrational fashion and rational dress compares
to have a whole range of different garments,
but they're extensively recognized as a looser corset or no corseted,
all m and a pair of bifurcated,
bifurcated,
um,
trousers such as bloomers and knickerbockers and no skirt or a shorter skirt.
So shocking was this change in dress in public space that it really divided the
nation.
Dress reform was incredibly controversial with many arguing that the public's
distaste for this radical form of mask analyzed clothing for women,
damaged women's freedom of movement,
and it really split women's cyclists and dress reformers alike.
And it was also of course time of expanding popular media,
especially fueled,
as I said by the popularity of cycling and lots of publications really targeted
women as these new consumers of cycling.
And The lady cyclist was one such publication,
very popular at the time.
It was launched in 1996 and it was edited by a man,
but it had lots of contributions from women.
And it put forward this really powerful new visual language and technological
imaginary,
the placed women firmly in cycling's fashionable set and carving a space for
them in what had been pretty much a masculine kind of cycling world.
So it was really important and the gave many of the permission to continue the
sport or provide incentive for the tentative.
However,
these publications also provide an awful lot of advice and um,
and suggestions for the lady cyclist and what they should do or not do,
what they should dress and not dress in.
And they'll have regular columns such as why a lady's cyclists should always
dress well cycling fashions.
They're illustrations of the ideal lady cyclist.
Um,
from the point of view of our various artists,
um,
as well as my favorite array,
yourself becoming Lee.
And overall they were,
it was really imperative that the lady cyclist appear feminine while Mobile,
um,
with emphasis on being graceful and neat and sensible and becoming charming,
dignified,
modest,
and more.
So you note how this discourse is quite different from men and cycling's a
discourse,
but it sensibly though we're firmly discouraged not to show any effort or strain
or cycling in order to maintain this kind of feminine form of Mobility.
So it's quite a lot of pressure then to be a lady cyclists for any of us.
You know what it's like to cycle.
So another thing by portraits were really popular in the 1890s.
It's kind of the equivalent of the selfie.
Now I imagine,
um,
having access to all these new technologies such as the bicycle,
a new cycle and garment,
and a camera illustrated great cultural cachet.
And you've got to admit,
Mrs Hh Timberlake here of Wigan is looking pretty elegant and dignified and
modest and charming and very feminine there,
but she's also wearing an awful lot of clothes and she's not moving
because the reality is that,
um,
it was actually quite difficult to look graceful and elegant and modest and,
graceful on a moving bicycle,
especially when you're wearing that many clothes.
Um,
because that many clothes can make you fall off your bike.
And it did because the reality of cycling in what was called ordinary dress was
very difficult skirts and petticoats called in chain rings.
As you'd imagine,
material wrapped around pedals flew into spokes.
It even blew cause in some cases dresses for quite wide.
It would even blew into wheels and blew up and even obscured cyclist view as
some of the,
um,
newspaper reports would indicate.
And newspapers also regularly noted with kind of gruesome detail,
I'm a counsel,
women dying or becoming disfigured as a result of cycling crashes often due to
their clothing.
And this discourse reinforced the idea that that many had that women weren't
natural cyclists.
Um,
and they were kind of not very confident and a bit technologically and
competent.
However,
it is very difficult to cycle wearing this many clothes,
especially when I'm,
it keeps making you fall off.
But the choice to cycling more appropriate cycle where such as more rational
dress at the time,
um,
wasn't necessarily socially safer cause cycling and more rational dress such as
bloomers and more removing your skirt would expose you to the potential spectrum
of responses from all classes of society.
And it could result in verbal and even physical assault.
Um,
cyclists were harassed in the street.
They'll subjected to rocks and sticks and incredibly rude remarks.
There were denied entry into places and they'll gossiped about kind of imagine
just kind of how difficult it would have been to kind of get out there and cycle
when you knew that was going to happen in different places.
So one of the reasons that women cyclists in cycle where elicited such responses
is that they were seen by some to be encroaching and what had previously been
men's lifestyles and privileges society feared women getting out alone.
Unchaperoned moving at speed.
Um,
and,
um,
in some cases even smoking,
the fact that it would lead women into these potentially kind of,
um,
bad behaviors and pursuit and lady cyclists were a favorite topic for discussion
and debate in the media and lots of poems and diatribes and cartoons kind of
really kind of use this in order to kind of generate discussion and debate and
audiences.
And I particularly love this image because she really doesn't look like she
cares at all about it.
You know,
she's,
she's overdressed,
you know,
look at that broach on a head.
Um,
she's not clearly very particularly good at cycling,
you know,
to just run someone off the road.
Um,
she's unchaperoned,
she's smoking and she's clearly a danger to others,
but she's just keep on going with it.
Um,
and clearly this cartoon is kind of mocking a lot of these fears,
but most threatening to some parts of society was the fact that women were out
there.
They were carving out new feminine modes and mobility.
There were unchaperoned,
they'll mimic it speed at different times and in different places than ever
before.
And cycling,
therefore for some was emblematic of women rejecting their natural roles at
home.
Um,
caring and bearing of children,
the carrying of bearing of others and their actions potentially threaten the
very kind of continuously of humanity.
This is how kind of intense the conversation was going.
What's going to happen if women are out there cycling and not helping to produce
healthy offspring.
Um,
so it really polarized society,
a female body on a bicycle,
how it moved,
how it was dressed swiftly became a site of intense public debate about the
broader role of women in society.
And as a result,
you had to be quite brave in some places to get out there and go writing.
However,
fortunately nothing was gonna stop quite a lot of women from cycling,
um,
after that experience,
you know,
the unparalleled excitement of it.
And there are many ways that women responded to what it become known as the
dress problem.
Some braved ordinary fashion on their bicycles and just suffered whatever kind
of crushes might happen.
Some war rational dress like kitty and her friends and brave the social
response,
some war.
Um,
some elicited sites,
specific strategies which involved wearing more at one garment for city riding
and then changing into something more appropriate for proper writing when nobody
could really see you and others responded.
Um,
inventively through the dress itself.
And this is what I've been particularly interested in and I don't know if anyone
knows of Rosacea Parker's great book.
There's a burst of stitch.
It relates to women's engagement in the art of embroidery,
but I think it really relates to sewing as well because she says the art of
embroidery has been the means of educating women into the Feminine Ideal and
approving they've obtained it,
but it has also provided a weapon of resistance to constraints of femininity.
So what I discovered in doing quite a lot of archival research about this period
of time is that quite a number of these pioneering women who really wanted to
cycle,
um,
and wanted to respond through the dress itself,
used all the tools and the skills and the networks at their disposal to redefine
the primary parameters of femininity through their clothing.
So
these challenges to women's freedom of movement created the conditions right for
invention.
And it turns out some of these pioneering women not only imagined designed,
made and war radical new forms of cycle where,
but they also patented their designs,
which is terrific for us.
Um,
the mid 1890s is mark not only by a boom in cycling,
but a boom in patenting as well.
Um,
I haven't got time to tell you about all the kinds of things that come together,
but handle eats in the book.
Um,
but there was a kind of a long history of patent reform that kind of slowly
coincides with the reform to the marriage when women's property act that
actually enabled them to have more control and power over their ideas.
Um,
but it was a remarkable time for inventiveness,
especially for and by women because cycling's dress problem was so mobilizing
for women that psycho or inventions became a primary vehicle for women's entry
into the world of patenting.
They became statistically relevant for the first time.
So they get talked about in new ways.
So what a patents have many,
have you done patent recent?
No,
me neither until this project to a what?
A patents.
A patent is a temporary monopoly on the economic benefit that can be derived
from an invention.
As such,
a pattern turns an idea until a form of property.
The person who has a new idea,
a patent asserts can own it in the same way that he or she can own land or
money.
Okay.
But why are patents interesting to sociologists and to you?
Well,
patterns,
uh,
provide an incredible material history of invention.
Um,
as Ruth Schwartz Cohen Rights,
if there's no such thing as a patent,
we would not know very much about inventors and patterns.
I think a fascinating design objects because inventors describing detail the
problem they're attempting to solve.
And in doing so,
provide us with a glimpse of the socio,
cultural context of the time.
The inventor tells them us about themselves,
their name,
address,
self identified,
vocation.
They're married status mostly for women.
They identify the problem,
then they tell us how they've solved it and they go into great detail about who
it's for,
what materials,
what technologies,
um,
how it relates to past inventions.
Um,
and the many ways that it can be put to use patterns.
We're also particularly good record of women's inventiveness.
Um,
as Zarina Khan says,
pattern records are inherently useful in this regard because they provide a
continuous source of information about market related activities of women.
So they're an amazing resource of firsthand accounts of women from this period.
They give voice to a group.
They're very often silenced by history.
We don't often hear much about them and they're also a continuous valuable
record.
You know,
they provide evidence of women as being creative inventors and continually
contributing to cycling's history.
You know,
when we often look at more conventional records,
women tend to pop up in the account.
This shows us that there were continually,
there's an evolving in connected history of their contributions and they present
a range of voices,
not just in a way try and full loud or more traditionally heroic kind of stories
that are conventionally successful.
Pattern databases record the work of all the ideas that go into the archive.
Uh,
regardless of whether or not they've actually been successfully taken out and
produced into something.
So there's still an incredibly useful body of data because it shows us what
people were thinking about and how they were drawing on the past to claim the
present and imagine different futures.
Um,
and they speak to future makers and users,
you know,
but they provide detailed instructions for somebody else and they provide all
that detail for somebody else to remake the invention.
So a little bit more on that in a second,
and they're not boring.
Um,
to be honest,
I was a bit concerned doing this much kind of patent research and hauling away
and kind of archives.
Um,
for a number of years it turned out because I'm more of an ethnographer,
I would spend time with people actually going and living with different
communities,
um,
doing lots of field work,
and interviewing people,
hanging out with people,
um,
building things.
It was quite lively and dynamic,
hang around with people who are alive.
So,
um,
eh,
it was a little bit concerned doing all of this as to whether it would be as
interesting as it turned out to be.
But it turns out the,
a story of Victorian inventors and patentees is far from a kind of dry and Dell
account,
relegated to the dusty corners of archives combined with geological research.
The race to patent ideas at the turn of last century is full of drama and
excitement and successful inventors were,
as Ruth Schwartz Cohen talks about,
they'll celebrate it in print and from the pulpit household names either in
their own right or because of the names of the companies they founded.
Newspapers quoted them,
popular magazines,
recounted the exploits and huge crowds turned out to hear about them.
It really was,
I think in the 1890s the equivalent of kind of the early.com boom or the turn of
the last century.
Lots of people were so excited by this potential of an idea could radically
change your future,
could really propel your sort of social mobility in ways that other kinds of
jobs or opportunities couldn't.
So,
and also look at the books.
I get to hang out with are enormous.
I should have had my hand in there for scale,
but they really were huge.
And uh,
invariably,
you know,
they're filled with all the dust of 1890s.
I would leave kind of wearing and bodied with kind of materiality.
And I see you're probably leaving some of myself in it as well.
That's another talk.
But I've been particularly influenced by feminist turn it in the archives to see
not only what is present in the archives but also what is absent and kind of
critically consider the politics that shape collections.
So as an installer,
you know,
it was written,
this involves a move from the archive as a source to archive as a subject.
And she talks about our carving is a process and thinking about it as a thing.
And likewise Kate icons work is really interesting about archives because she
says it's not so much a turn to the past,
but another way to understand the present.
So I began to see these kind of spaces and materials as opportunities to find to
piece together these stories.
Cause it's certainly not sitting there waiting to just read them.
Particularly Women's stories in the past.
They're kind of everywhere.
The fragmented,
it's a way of trying to piece these pieces together,
but also trying to resist making it a smooth narrative because I don't know for
sure.
So I'm trying to piece them together but still maintain kind of an opens
opportunity for other people to interpret it.
This material.
So what were they inventing?
Looking across these patents?
Essential aim becomes clear and it's quite ambitious.
They aim to create garments that did two things that operated as a form of
successful form of cycle where while still giving the appearance of an ordinary
skirt.
So they're trying to make something that does both things.
And you can see this is just a few cutouts for a number of different patterns.
You know,
it will have the parents of an ordinary is walking skirt.
My invention relates to improvements and lady skirts that were rendered them
equally adaptable for cyclists and be indistinguishable.
They're trying to really ambitiously do two things in one and there are a number
of ways that they did this.
And I've identified five themes.
Yeah.
Inventive solution number one.
Um,
attach women to their clothing.
A inventors used a whole array of straps and buckles and even metal belts and a
whole range of,
of chains as well.
Um,
uh,
to prevent a skirt from flapping and flying about which was the problem.
And funny enough,
more male inventors thought this was a better idea.
And then the female inventors,
women were more about taking the stuff away rather than adding more things on
there.
Okay.
Inventive solution number two,
uh,
tailor the scope to fit the bike.
So this cuts some of the bulk of the skirt and the kind of layers of petticoats
which were flapping around.
And the aim was to fit the skirt over both sides of the back wheel without going
into it,
which is what this image is showing there.
But when you moved away from your bicycle,
it was indiscernible that you were wearing cycle where,
so at limited some of the potential for crashes,
but the scope was still flapping quite close to that back wheel.
And there are a lot of critics of this particular invention.
Inventive solution number three is what I call builtin.
So you might love your bloomers,
it might be hurricane on them,
but maybe you didn't want anyone else to see them.
So I'm perhaps you were committed to rational dress and women's suffrage,
but you weren't so keen and having things thrown at you in public.
Um,
so you wore them but you kept them hidden by a skirt.
So there are a number of different ideas that had bloom is sewn into them,
replacing the petticoats or re re removed a lot of those layers.
And if your scope did fly out,
then you'll still kind of cupboard
inventive.
Solution number four is what I technically call the really big bloomers.
Um,
they look like a skirt.
They're so big as you can see,
kind of hid the fact that you've got bifurcation going on there.
Um,
and he drew independently moving legs to a degree but still freed your legs to
pedal and kept the loose material in check.
And,
um,
I really like these and I've made a number of pairs of these and they're
phenomenal for snacks and cyclists,
really like their snacks.
You can get a lot of pockets happening in there with a lot of lot of food
without anyone knowing.
Inventive solution number five,
convertible costumes.
Now these game garments really ambitiously aimed for both respectable fashion,
urban street wear and cycle where so the inventors engineer deliberately conceal
technological systems into their skirt.
So into their skirts,
I'm using police systems and gathering devices and cords and buttons and loops
and other mechanisms into the seams and hems and waistbands that enabled with
whereas the secretly switch from modal,
uh,
identities from per ambulant walking to cycling,
um,
when they need it.
And this is the theme I was,
became very struck by and more women than men really took to this.
And this was the biggest theme out of all of those.
So what do we do next?
Um,
I really want to see these things in action.
Like how do they work?
How were they made?
How were they repaired?
Did they work at all?
So I'd been around,
um,
so many of the museums and galleries in the UK looking at Victorian sportswear
and I don't know if anyone's done this,
but it's amazing.
You go into museums and galleries and they have such an amazing collection of
Victorian garments as well as other things and curators are really keen to bring
them up out of the archive because they're not all on show and to um,
provide them to you to explore and engage with.
Um,
and there's lots,
there's,
for me there was yachting and horse riding and gymnastics and swimming and
golfing and walking and all sorts of things,
but no cycle,
um,
convertible cycle outfits.
Um,
so I haven't found it yet.
Any evidence of these,
even though I will show an example to show very clearly that quite a number of
them were made successful and distributed and worn by people.
So why aren't they available considering lots of other things are,
well,
you talked to correct curators and think about this for awhile.
Cycleway gets worn out.
I don't know how many of you think about your old cycling next and think the
National Gallery needs them.
Probably not.
Um,
so inventions also were hidden in plain sight.
One of the kinds of purposes of them was that no,
no one knew about it unless you were transforming them.
So it's um,
they're designed not to be seen and quite possibly,
if you don't know what you're looking for when you just get one of these skirts,
you may not know that these things are built into them.
And of course women's invention in the past not necessarily recognized or highly
valued for what it is.
Um,
and as per agenda conventions of the time,
you know,
either ignored or slowly written out of history as well.
And even if they were available.
Um,
these garments are really made for mobility.
They're live dynamic,
you know,
transformable convertible objects.
It's really hard to gain insights from them,
even though it's amazing when you go in,
this is kind of what you get.
You get the object,
you get these tools of investigation being,
um,
a tape measure pencil,
some paper,
a magnifying glass,
and that's how you interview costumes.
And it's interesting the cannabis recalcitrants as human interviewees,
they'll tell you some things and you know,
keep other things to themselves.
But even if I had these costumes,
um,
as I came to understand a lot of these really only makes sense on and with the
body,
they're hard to understand off the body.
Um,
and understandably,
you know,
the curators probably wouldn't have let me put them on,
convert them and go for a bike ride.
And frankly,
these are so small,
this body was not going to fit into them.
And I'm calm.
I'm committed to this project,
but I've hadn't been wearing a corset for it.
So after doing a lot of this research,
um,
and finding no evidence of the material,
material garments,
um,
we figured we had the instructions in the patents.
We have the step by step detailed,
um,
provisions by the research,
the inventors themselves.
We should make some.
So I'm,
I'd been working with a team of a pattern cutter,
a weaver and an artist to remake a collection of these.
And I've been calling this,
I'm making things to make sense of things along the way.
And it builds on a long history as you probably know in science and the history
of technology for reproductions and,
um,
replications where you explore through practice are the forms are kind of
sensory and bodily knowledge and asked,
you know,
what can you learn from doing this that you wouldn't just get from doing textual
analysis of a patent.
And Patents provide really rich instruction for it because the nature of pattern
is such that the language and drawings must provide full,
clear an exact description.
Interventions such as well enable others skilled in the art which are pertains
to make use of it.
So in the case of,
uh,
clothing,
patent,
anyone knowledgeable in the art of sewing should be able to reproduce these.
Um,
and we also argued that making these kinds of credit relationship with people
who'd lived to 130 years before we got into this dialogue,
you know,
with the inventors through their inventions and conducted an ethnography of
making along the way.
And it got incredibly messy because I'm a sociologist so I don't get a lot of
studio space and this is quite a big sociology office bills,
a lot of floor work going on here.
Um,
so I stuck a camera to the ceiling.
I go pro and took photographs every 10 seconds for the last six weeks of the
project.
You can imagine how much data I have from this.
Um,
and may timelapse films,
which I don't have one to show you,
but they're on my website.
And just the amount of movement and dynamism capture from that perspective
became another form of data as well as kind of doing field notes.
So we made a collection of five of these garments.
Um,
I said I would make five skirts,
but it really doesn't make sense if you don't make the whole thing.
So ended up making about 27 pieces of clothing as well as all the iterations
because trying to work out how to build things like police systems into skirts,
it turns out you need to do a few iterations of different scales to even work
out what that is.
Cause I don't know about you,
but I've never seen a police system in the skirt before this project.
Um,
so I'm actually wearing one of the convertible costumes now.
I'm not normally dress like this.
Um,
so I can introduce it to you.
Good.
Um,
I am wearing a patented convertible Victorian cycling costume that was,
um,
designed by Alice by grave,
a dressmaker of Brixton in 1895.
She was 35 years old when she lodged her UK patent for improvements in ladies
cycling skirts and the aim of the design.
Um,
I literally,
one thing,
if you've ever patented or know about patenting,
you'll be amazed at how quick this is.
The complete specification was left on the 1st of November,
1895 and it was accepted on the 6th of December,
1895.
I don't think that happens anymore.
It's quite exciting.
Um,
the aim of her design was to provide a skirt,
um,
that was proper for where we're neither on or off the machine.
So she's trying to this ambitious thing look like you're in reputable and
respectable streetwear and then converted into cycle,
were unable to convert it back again.
So she clearly knew she was onto something cause she went on to patent it in
three other countries.
She patented it in,
um,
Switzerland in Canada and in the US.
MMM.
And a common difficulty when doing kind of patents studies is losing the trail.
Um,
really quickly.
often the inventors named get lost when a commercial organization picks up an
idea when they renamed it and distributed.
This didn't happen with Alice by grave.
Um,
Yoga,
the British fashion house picked up this patent.
Clearly I recognize the value of it and,
um,
proceeded to distribute the design under her name,
the biograph convertible skirt,
which is obviously really good for us.
And tracing this.
And as an editorial in popular cycling magazines and newspapers and periodicals
started to appear.
Um,
the microwave of convertible skirt was quite a,
it captured the nation's imagination.
It was regulated,
demonstrated at all the big cycling shows,
lots of reviews were written about it,
um,
uh,
in not only the cycling kind of magazines,
but also in much kind of bigger,
broader kind of newspapers.
And it started to be distributed all around the UK.
And this is an example of one of 'em Yeager's distributors that really kind of
drives this forward,
you know,
the new bigroad convertible skirt,
and suitable for cycling,
et Cetera.
And,
um,
it was written about in us media because he traveled over there in order to
lodge your patent and do new deals.
Um,
so she,
um,
here it is in the San Francisco Chronicle and then Saint Louis,
times,
um,
and it even wound its way to Australia.
Uh,
there's distributed from Yag by Yeager and it was sold in David Jones.
If people know it's a big retailer that's still around today and it was
available in Sydney and in Melbourne.
And again was talked about and lots of newspapers around the place.
So this is an example of not all patents,
you know,
clearly leave the patent archive,
but some of them did.
And this very much did.
So before I show you the invention a little bit more about her family's
influences to kind of understand how she got to what she got to.
Um,
her mother was a dressmaker and so as Alice by grave,
she self identifies as one.
Um,
her parents had a watching clock making shop,
um,
in Chelsea,
a king's road and her brother and sister in law were professional cyclists.
So watching clock making a bit of sewing,
cycling coming together.
So what did she design?
This is one of her drawings.
So,
um,
she's gotta be wearing a Corset,
but you think when we get the size of that waste versus their shoulders,
um,
anyway,
so he seems to be kind of holding onto her waist in some formation.
There's something going on there.
So this is what you'd look like as you were walking along the street,
you know,
and not looking like a cyclist.
You get to your bicycle and then you do this to it.
So you leave your bicycle,
you look like that,
you do this.
So what she's effectively done,
and I'll move around the front now so you can see,
she's got effectively a very simple a line skirt that otherwise you wouldn't
guess that I was a cyclist,
but then hidden at the waistband or a series of chords that she has in button
holes that don't have any buttons that says part of a system.
Um,
and you would rush up the front like a curtain.
We were starting to call this a skirt and being a kid and,
and you would tie it at the waist.
She actually had a much cleverer design,
um,
cleaning than what we've done with this because I'd broken this several times.
Um,
it adds a new level of,
um,
potential malfunction to a talk when you can ruin your dress as well as your
PowerPoint.
Um,
and then usefully she has a series of police at the back as well that she's,
as you can see,
I've got different,
um,
that she's looped through to the front.
So you're not fattening at the back.
You would grab this and then you would rush up the back as well and tie this
off.
So then suddenly you've,
um,
revealed some of your bloomers,
but not too much of them.
And I actually cycled here today cause I don't live very far away and I wasn't
going to them change that we might be quicker and it really does work.
And you were tied them off and hide them.
And then she talked about how it was still kind of an attractive skirt,
you know,
still festoons she called it over the hips,
which to be honest,
I didn't know what that meant until I started to festoon over the hips.
Um,
so incredibly kind of useful.
But the nice thing then about it is that you would then,
if once you've got a few bike,
it's called the quick change convertible skirt.
You would undo your knots
and then drop it straight back down again and then it would just hide.
So,
and I think what this research really highlights,
um,
is the role of women as,
as engineers and as designers and as kind of feminist inventors.
You know,
these stories really add new layers and textures to cycling history.
They depict women as critically engaged,
creative citizens,
actively driving social and technical change.
And this is really important because with few exceptions,
women are mostly framed as being kind of passive or ornamental.
Bystanders caught up in waves of technical change,
symbols of social upheaval,
not catalysts of it.
Um,
and so what this research does,
it sits in the context of kind of feminist reclamation projects,
um,
because it brings to light,
it's accounts of women's engagements with cycling that demonstrate that weren't
just located on the,
you know,
as bystanders but actually actively engaged trying to make change.
And in claiming they're doing this by putting their radically kind of different
clad bodies add in public space,
but also claiming their ideas through patenting was not only a practical way of
sharing and distributing the ideas,
but it was also a political act because they were carving out new space on the
road.
And also in legal and economic worlds.
You know,
there were being talked about in this whole new world of invention,
the annual patent controller reports sounded a little bit surprised every year
when they would talk about the statistics of women's inventiveness cause it was
new in the 1890s.
So,
and also cycle where,
you know,
as I went into this project to ask,
how,
how a cycle where mattered,
it's always mattered.
It mattered right from the beginning.
And it comes still matters today.
And although society's changed dramatically over the last two centuries,
many of the issues that marginalized women and in inhibited their cycling uptake
remain remarkably kind of familiar,
um,
such as the assumption that kind of physical exertion is incompatible with
femininity and how women are still disproportionately kind of harassed in public
space often in relation to what they were.
These issues are not new,
but women have always creatively and critically responded to these challenges in
order to do the things that they want to do in spite of some.
So why don't we know what,
why do we know so little about these kinds of inventions?
You know,
um,
who else and what else don't we know about is the questions of this kept on
coming out while I was doing this kind of stuff.
Um,
how many other amazing ideas are kind of out there,
either hidden or undervalued or kind of erased from our histories?
How do we seek out other ideas like this or,
or listen to other kinds of silenced voices?
What else could we know?
And I just want to leave with a question you'll,
if you learn more about a wider range of inventors and inventions,
might it change how we think about and inhabit the present and,
and how would it help us kind of imagine and make different futures?
And I'll finish there.
Thank you very much.